I love the holidays in Apocalypto
weather is dusty and the coffee tastes
extra pumpkin spicy this holiday season
has definitely descended into chaos now
that if the duplo savages destroyed our
land
happy holidays sorry did I interrupt
your brooding sesh yeah it's no biggie I
was just filling everyone in I'm not
tough it is to live here but you know
it'll cheer everyone up please miss a
holiday party you said it no yes No ah
come on I've got a plan step one get
everyone together in the town square
step 2 ice skating step 3 decorate this
town for the most tinsel tastic holiday
party apocalypse burg has ever seen
here poofy captioning this holly-jolly
Mary Mary let's go
Lucy this tree lights up you'll be able
to see it from we don't need any more
unwanted attention relax just think this
is a quite little neighborhood shindig
with just a few of our closest friends
and a tree you may or may not be able to
see we all deserve
however you celebrate let's celebrate to
gather more eggnog sir hmm I wait all
year for this sweet nectar of joy
indubitably answers
my tummy is a little rumbling to light
it up kid
there she closed I like darkness this
isn't super beautiful
[Music]
looks like a sauna Patty's apocalypse
burgers of visit yes
I mean oh no I knew it
everyone battle stance I was not
expecting that
[Music]
alfrid this letter only has eight abs
now cool bro
but sir knowed me once everything was
awesome now everything is okay Lucy I
brought you coffee coffee the bitter
liquid that provides the only semblance
of pleasure left in these dark times oh
my gosh did I interrupt you brooding
just now times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
Oh
Barry the door is slowly closing
oh the pain its cane so cold see that
wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
hang on your fronds planet we're going
[Music]
you mind if I save your life not at all
who are you names danger vest galaxy
defending archaeologist cowboy and
Raptor trainer I don't get it we'll help
me rescue my friends anywhere near the
star system it's ruled by an alien coin
only the toughest you're gonna get out
of there alive
i'm mcqueen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil vibes here I could
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable
hey guys they'll go back the horse was
much more palatable on your feet
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding no I don't
[Music]